bonsoir Édouard Bert bonsoir Elisabeth
Lemoine
vous voulez changer de profil oui je
vous assure
[Rires]
est-ce qu'il y a des 80 ans dans la
salle je pense pas non la covid a pris
les meilleurs
désigner hier adoubé aujourd'hui
richissounac officiellement nommé
Premier ministre britannique par le roi
Charles III il succède à l'éphémère lise
trust qui début septembre à peine ont
rencontré en tant que première ministre
la reine Elizabeth II nous créerons un
avenir qui vaut les sacrifices à
notamment déclaré Richie sunac qui est
vraiment richiste Unac alors
figurez-vous d'abord que c'est un très
danseur regardez
[Musique]
à
Ibiza voilà je vous vois la bouche alors
on a pas la date précise ça a été
diffusé juste après le dernier
confinement ça change tout de même faut
le dire de Winston Churchill ou de
Margate
[Musique]
je vous demande de vous arrêter
[Applaudissements]
ton grammage mais tu comprends
des vététistes demandent des comptes à
ce chasseur ici en rouge
l'un des promeneurs montre même les
traces de plomb laissé sur son corps
en tout 3 membres du groupe ont été
touchés dont deux sur leur casque de
vélo Clara film la scène par réflexe
elle raconte aujourd'hui sa peur on
s'est dit c'est pas possible il va pas
tirer alors que il nous a vu on venait
de lui dire bonjour et pourtant il a mis
le fusil en Joux il a fait un tirant on
a entendu les les plombs ricochets sur
la route et moi j'ai reçu donc un plomb
dans le casque un de nos amis aussi et
mon papa sur la côte et aussi au niveau
de la poitrine je vais vous dire une
chose
il y a un temps pour rire il y a un
temps pour arrêter il y a un temps pour
échanger la vérité des vérités j'adore
les phrases les vérités c'est merveilles
les vérités sont on est calmez-vous
puisque sans contrefaçon je suis un
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le 1 s'il vous plaît elle sort avec une
robe du soir
[Musique]
il y a beaucoup de trucs dans votre tête
parce que à chaque fois il pense à des
trucs bizarres il n'ose pas lui dire
ils attendent leur goûter
jusqu'à 100 contrefaçon je descends
garçon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
que c'était pas la [ __ ] qui sort en
robe du soir ah vous étiez sur la
[ __ ] à la verticale ah j'avais pas
du tout pensé à ça moi elle sort du soir
pardon
personne n'avait pensé mais il y a que
vous pour penser à ça personne ne me
pisse dans le cerveau tout simplement
dans un premier temps parce que c'est
impossible physiologiquement parlant à
moins qu'on mette une petite sonde dans
l'oreille et qu'on urine à l'intérieur
mais non
[Musique]
écoute je pense qu'il y a tellement
mieux à faire avec mes mains si j'arrive
pas à dormir
une polémique en Indre-et-Loire de
diocèse de tout organiser une prière
pour les malades la semaine dernière à
la basilique Saint-Martin tout ce qu'il
y a de plus classique et d'honorable de
la part de l'église sauf que la
polémique est née du slogan choisi sur
la fiche vous allez la voir laissez-vous
toucher laissez-vous toucher une phrase
plein de sens trop peut-être la
communication c'est un métier souligne
certains cet avocat en droit de
l'enfance adressé aux victimes de la
bêtarthu qui sévissaient justement en
Touraine la campagne depuis été retirée
de la page Facebook du diocèse